- Hello.
Welcome to the Daily
Homeroom Sal Khan here
from Khan Academy for those of you.
For those of you that this is
the first time you're joining
this is something that we're
doing on a daily basis,
so that we all feel connected
in this time of school
closures and social distancing.
It's a time for you, whether
you're a student, a parent,
a teacher to ask questions.
So, whatever social media
platform you're watching this on,
start asking questions
on the messages below.
We have team members
who are surfacing some
of those questions up
to me and our guests,
so that we can answer them for you.
We want this to be as
interactive as possible.
The reason why we think it's important
to have this connection is, you know,
we have all these
materials on Khan Academy
to support you and your
various academic subjects,
we publish things like the daily schedules
to structure your days in different ways.
All of this is available
for free at khanacademy.org.
We've been doing parent and
teacher webinars as well.
But then to support on top of that,
and I do wanna remind everyone
we are a not for profit organization
with a mission a free
world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And so, if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating
to Khan Academy we were already running
at a deficit before the COVID crisis
and ever since the
schools closed our traffic
is up over two and a half times
what it normally would be.
I do wanna give a special thanks
to several corporate partners
who have stepped up in
record time to make sure
that we can keep running,
although we've continued
to run at a deficit, Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
and Novartis.
If any of you, potential
corporate partners
are out there listening.
Please think about helping us do this
because we still need more help
from corporate partners,
from individual gifts,
even if you can donate $3, $5, $10.
It all makes a difference.
So, today we have a
very exciting guest we,
yesterday we talked about mental health
and today we're gonna talk a little bit
about physical health.
And I think we all have a sense, you know,
we have those daily
schedules where we said,
"hey this is where you can
work on math on Khan Academy,
"this, we could work on
English language arts,"
but we had breaks in there
and we kinda threw in,
"hey, you could do yoga now,
"you could go for a run,"
but today we have an expert,
Michelle Carter from Shape America.
So, Michelle before the COVID crisis.
What were you doing or what are you doing?
(laughing)
- Well that's a great question.
I think we've all been kinda sidetracked
with this COVID-19,
but Shape America is a,
Shape America is a nonprofit
association for health
and PE teachers, we
serve as the voice of--
- [Sal] Is it, I can't...
Maybe, check with Philippe.
Are y'all hearing Michelle?
'Cause I can't hear.
Oh, okay, so Philippe hears her,
so maybe something's wrong with my.
(speaking faintly)
- Okay, I'm here, I just.
Can you hear me now?
- [Sal] Hear you.
- Can you hear me now?
Okay.
So, as I was saying the
Shape America serves
as the voice of over 200,000
health and PE teachers
and so, we're dedicated to
helping health education teachers
and physical education
teachers with what they need
to teach students how to live
their best life physically
and emotionally so I'm a
former health and PE teacher
and so I really serve as a subject matter
and content expert for Shape America.
Okay so, one of the things
that's really important
when you are thinking
about creating physical
activity experiences
for your children, are that you want
to accumulate about 60 minutes
of daily physical activity
for school aged children
around ages six to 17 years old
and this is recommendations
that come from CDC
and for preschool aged children,
thinking about three to five years old,
there isn't a set time,
but just making sure
that there's getting physical
activity throughout the day.
So, some specific examples
of the kinds of things
that you can do with your younger children
are using things around your house.
It doesn't have to be
elaborate, doesn't have
to even take a lot of time as
long as you're just providing
that opportunity for your
children to move and one example
is using things like paper
plates or if you have pillows
or even a hand towel something
flat and you can spread
that around an area and have
them jump from rock to rock.
And so this works on the skills
of balance and local motor
and leaping and then if
you're able to go outside,
you could use sidewalk chalk
and draw circles and have them leaping.
Really, at the early childhood age
around three to five, imaginative movement
is really good for young children.
Having them move their
bodies in different ways,
so asking them, "can you
make your body like a circle,
"can you make your body like
a triangle or the letter S?"
And so getting them to be creative
while they're moving their body
and exploring how their body
moves in different ways.
I know we probably, the
go to exercise of movement
is walking, and it's really
good even for little ones
but specifically for little ones having
to practice those local
motor movements again
as well as galloping and
skipping and hopping,
they can do that along the sidewalk.
So, just thinking about ways
that they can move while walking.
In your house or even outside you
can ask them, "touch three
things that are green,
"touch one thing that is
red," so just having them,
you're working on colors and
then following directions
and they're moving at the same
time, so very simple things
and then of course, one that
is easy to do, is with music
and using music as a great tool.
So, playing different types
of music with fast tempos
or slower tempos and asking them,
"well how can you move your
body to the beat of this song?"
So, if they're moving fast,
they can get kind of upbeat
or if they're slow,
and they move their body
slow, classical music
is a great opportunity to use
because the variations in the tempo
or if there's loud drums
or clashing symbols.
And so, we have a lot of
resources at shapeamerica.org,
especially on our early
childhood calendars
are really great.
We have tons of resources
there with plethora of ideas
for our little, our young
friends, our young children.
So, specifically going back
to school aged children,
that's categorized as six
to 17 year old children.
And so, really making sure
they get an hour of moderate
to vigorous physical
activity throughout the day.
So, that means their heart rate is up,
they're breathing harder
and if they did it long
enough, they get sweaty.
- Hi, Michelle
- So it doesn't have.
Hi, hi!
- So, apologies, we have a little bit
of technical difficulties,
so I'll be stepping
in until Sal gets set up
with questions for Michelle.
- No problem.
- Yeah, so I think we have
a couple of good questions
that are already coming in.
- All right, awesome.
- We have a really good question
from Facebook Michelle,
it's from Scott Yang.
And the question is,
"Michelle What do you,
"what if you live in a tiny home?"
How do you exercise inside a tiny space?
- Absolutely.
So, you don't need a
lot of space necessarily
but this is where creativity comes
in really great, so one
thing that, using the things
that you already have in your house.
So, one example is if you have Candyland
or another card game or Monopoly
or something like that you can
use the cards from that game,
and assign exercises to the colors
or the suits or the character.
And then, so for example, in Candyland
if you draw a blue
color, you can do running
in place for 20 seconds
or something like that.
And one thing you'll hear me talk
about a lot through this
is allowing your children
to have choice, that's really important
so, ask them, "what do you want,
"what should we do if we pick blue?"
"What should we do if we pick red?"
So, getting them involved
and coming up with the rules of the game.
Hi Sal.
- Hey, Michelle!
I could finally hear you,
so apologies everyone.
- Good good.
- But Philippe did some
heroic back end rewiring
of everything it looks like we're all good
and thanks Dan for being able
to step in and Dan's always
in the background helping us
so, I should always be thanking him,
and it sounds like you already got started
and I think I got a
sense of where y'all are.
I guess, maybe one way to
think about it is, what is,
maybe you just said this
so I'm late to this party.
What is a target amount
of physical activity
that you would like
children to be getting,
maybe of different agents.
- Yes, so, for that school age group.
Six to 17 years old, they're
about an hour of 60 minutes
of physical activity
and so we're saying moderate to vigorous.
So, they're breathing
harder heart rate is up
and if they were to do this
activity long enough, you know,
they'd start working up a
sweat for younger children
that's preschool age, there
isn't necessarily a set time,
but just providing opportunities
for physical activity
and movement and imaginative
movement throughout the day,
so that they can explore
how their body moves.
- Yeah, and for those younger
crowd it's almost hard
to stop them from moving.
So they (laughing)
- Yeah their bodies, our bodies.
Yeah.
- I once, for kicks, put a step
tracker on my five year old
and saw what happened and he
has a lot of steps in his day.
But that's interesting.
- Oh, I'm down with it.
- It's kind of a little more
rigorous, a walk is nice
but if you can maybe work
up a sweat, dancing, yoga,
running, some type of,
you know, shooting hoops,
you know, socially distance
just with your family,
I guess, stuff like that.
- Yeah so, walking is a
great is a great exercise
and you can make walking, more intense too
by speeding up your pace,
or looking to go up hills,
even adding in skipping
and things like that
to make it a little bit more challenging.
So, walking is, I know
it's kind of a go to thing
'cause it's easy to do
and it is very effective,
so walking is great.
You can even throw in other things
with other movements like lunges or squats
and things like that just to
ramp it up a little bit, too.
- What do you think about pacing
is it an hour all at once,
or do you imagine it being
three, 20 minute sessions
over the course of the day?
So, I think breaking it up is the best.
We kind of don't wanna just get our bout
of physical activity in one time
and then be sedentary the rest of the day.
So, one of our recommendations is to,
is getting, using creating a recess time.
I know you all have been talking a lot
and we've all been talking
about the importance
of creating these routines.
So again, creating this routine of,
if you know you have lunch
around 12 or 12:30 schedule in
that 20 to 30 minutes
of dedicated physical
activity time before lunch,
and that's really beneficial
because what it does
to, is before lunch, it.
They're getting that energy out they come
and they're ready to eat,
they're gonna be more likely
to eat those vegetables,
and those fruits those healthy foods
that you're putting in front of them
and it also serves as
like a cooldown period.
So, that after lunch if
you're ready to get back
into the learning aspect into
academics they're settled
and they're focused and ready to learn.
That's super helpful and
my sense of it is not only
is it important for the
physical activity component
but that blood flowing
throughout the whole body
is actually useful for the learning itself
so that's why it's good
to go back and forth.
So, we're getting a ton of
questions on social media.
Oh, go ahead.
Keep it.
- No, no, no, I'm ready for questions.
- Okay.
Okay, so let's see there's a couple of
from YouTube Ashutosh asks,
"hi, Sal, how can someone keep a teen
"doing physical activities
who cannot go outside,
"because of living in
a congested urban area,
"and they like coding."
I don't know if those are the same,
(laughing)
but someone who lives in, you
know, you live in New York
in a, you know, dense environment
there might not be a green space outside.
- Green space or maybe safety issues
or something just not access, definitely.
That's a great question.
So, one thing that is very important
in this opportunity that comes
with this crisis is that,
allowing students to take
ownership of their health
and allowing them for choice.
So, if they can create their own schedules
and decide how they want to
move and allow some creativity.
I think that's really
important for them to do,
to choose things that
are exciting for them
and that they like to do,
to create their own movement
and so we have a few resources,
especially within our take home packet
that kinda guides them through that.
So, like with the physical activity log,
some guidance on how
to create some of these things,
we have these movement
calendars like our mind
and body calendar that
they can follow along with
and different types of
exercises like that.
Online too, if they're into coding
and I know we always stress about,
you know, screen time but if
they're using the screen time
to find different types
of ways to be active.
I know there's lots of websites.
I'll just, Fitness Blender is one
where they can create their own,
they can kind of tailor
it to what they wanna do.
So, creating goals and so
we can get into goal setting
with that and allowing
them to take ownership
'cause we really wanna set the stage
for them to be able to keep this as are,
they're entering into adulthood
and see the value in it.
Awesome, we got a lot
more questions, this one
from Shao Luo in Facebook.
This is interesting.
"My daughter is asking if 1000 jump ropes
"is enough exercise for
a day for a 14 year old."
That sounds pretty intense. (laughing)
- That does sound pretty
intense and a very specific
so, I think it would be
more about the time spent.
If it took you 30 minutes to
do 1000 jump ropes you'd want
to look at okay that's,
I got half of my activity
and so what are other ways
can I get movement in.
It's good for all of us, you
know, children especially to,
you know, try not to
be sitting for too long
and one setting so that's
really good, 1000 jump ropes.
But if you could also find
other opportunities to get up
and even just for a few minutes,
I mean, take a quick break
if you have stairs in your house
or in your apartment building, you know,
walking up and down the stairs
for a couple of minutes,
challenge yourself in those ways.
Those are great ways to, to continue
to add to that minutes,
you really wanna get
those 60 minutes, if you can, in a day.
- Yeah, no, but it sounds like, Shao,
you have a pretty hardcore,
a daughter, but, yeah,
she could keep going.
- Yeah, keep going.
1000 thousand is really good.
- That's good.
I've tried, I used to be into jump rope,
it might not be physically obvious,
but, 1000, yeah, I mean
because if you're doing it fast
with a fast rope you can, you're going
about two per second so
yeah it's about, you know,
5, 10 minutes of--
- But it's a good example
of if you have a jump rope at home,
you can use the jump rope
to get your heart rate up
and it doesn't take a lot of
space, you could also use it
to help stretch or use
it to create balancing
and different exercise
with a jump rope too so.
- Yeah, so the other question,
so this is an interesting one.
I think a lot of people having
this question generally,
this is from Sohome Sanu
on Facebook is running,
walking on trails outside
safe during the coronavirus.
So, from my understanding
of what I've read
on the CDC guidelines,
it is safe to be outside.
As long as you're not coming
into that, within that six feet
of someone else, so it's still okay
to take your children outside.
You just don't, you know, it's not as safe
to have them playing with other children
or that close contact, but
certainly go outside with them.
We did a chalk your walk challenge
on social media that was really fun.
So, allowing them still get outside
and thinking about those ways
that they can move, I mean,
even if it's in your driveway
or if there's a sidewalk.
Draw big squiggle lines on the floor
and have them try balancing
and moving in those pathways.
Use the music as a really good opportunity
if you can play music and
have them move to the music.
Another thing is that we're,
as adults, we're a little
bit further removed
from physical education class so ask them,
what do you do in class
and what are some things
that you think you can teach us to do
that you've learned in your,
your health and PE classes
to get us moving.
And kids are so creative
that they'll come up with that
but I encourage people
if they can, you know,
take them outside, and
still use those trails,
just be mindful about how
much they're being used
and then also follow your state.
If you have a stay at home order
and making sure you look into
if you can go outside and
use those public facilities.
Yeah, I know personally, you know,
if not far outside I think a
lot of us would find this even
that much more difficult.
You know, in my neighborhood
I'm seeing a lot
of people going for walks and runs,
we have a nice park locally,
we have some trails not too far away,
and it's really just about
keeping that distance,
you know, it's almost
funny, our neighborhood,
you can walk and people
just part, you know,
far more than six feet.
But I think that's, it's
always good to be prudent.
So, let's see, this is, I guess
is more of a Khan Academy question,
although maybe we might work
together on this Michelle
from Camilla on YouTube,
any plans of having PE
health on Khan Academy?
I felt like PE at school
- Ooh, great question.
- Was lacking, only ever played football
so I'm learning how to be active
and healthy in ways I enjoy.
You know, that's definitely an
interesting idea but in the,
in the meantime, there's
a lot of stuff obviously
on the internet on YouTube
on Shape America's website.
You know, in our schedules I put some
of my favorite activities
that you can find on YouTube,
like some of these dancing
things where you have to,
you know, just dance or
Dance Dance Revolution
that type of stuff,
yoga, there's a lot of,
I mean there's unlimited stuff on YouTube,
you could find but it is interesting
if we did something as well.
- Right.
And so, I do wanna make a distinction
that was a great question
Camilla for a little plug here
for Shape America is
just that distinguishing
between physical activity
and physical education
so physical activity is just movement,
and any kinda movement where
you're expending energy.
But physical education is really important
and especially health education
and I think we can really
see it in this moment
is that, were, there are
standards and objectives
that go along with actual
learning and physical education.
So, I've heard a lot of stories
of, I'll give you example,
of people who were athletes in school,
and their coaches were
telling them what to do
but as soon as they lost that coach,
they were no longer involved
in that sport, they no longer,
they found themselves they
didn't know how to actually take
that, what I keep talking
about that ownership
of how to take care of their health
and their wellness
and so with health and physical education,
it's teaching them those skills
so that when they do, are an adult.
They know how to be physically active,
they have the skills
so that they can be physically
active for a lifetime.
They do have the skills to
take care of their mental
and emotional health as well.
And so we see it's very
important right now
because we're at home.
And so we're finding challenges
of being physically active
we're also finding challenges
of taking care of our, our emotional
and our mental well being as well.
So, if you ever change your
mind Sal, Shape America
is here to help you with that. (laughing)
- [Sal] No, we might take you up on that.
- [Michelle] And providing
resources around that.
- And that's a really
good distinction you made
which is, it's not,
I mean the physical activity is important,
especially in this time, but
it's that plus the knowledge,
the frameworks the self
agency that you can be
that can be taught in a
traditional physical education
or health class.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- So, let's see someone from YouTube.
Actually, this is in her
Facebook, Kim Randall asks,
"Can your ability to run
while keeping oxygenated
"be compromised by wearing a mask,
"as the current guidelines suggest?"
I guess in some places they
are recommending wearing a mask.
- Right.
Well, I'm not sure, you
would probably wanna consult
with a doctor 'cause yes
I, you know, wearing a mask
can impede your breathing,
and it could make labor your breathing
so I would probably err
on the side of caution
with using a mask.
While doing something
that's very strenuous
and you're taking a lot
of, your breathing in,
you're breathing harder
and you need more oxygen.
So, walking with a mask is absolutely fine
but if you're doing something like,
high intensity interval training,
you might wanna do that somewhere
where you don't need to wear a mask.
- Yeah, I remember when
they had the fires here
in California and the air quality wasn't
so great I was wearing one of those N95s
and, yeah, it is very hard
to run with an N95 mask on.
- Yes, definitely
- You don't get a lot of air through.
So, this is an interesting
question it's both academic
and from a physical
education point of view,
it's from YouTube.
- Sure.
- Mynontraditionallife,
that's their username,
any advice for kids who are
resisting following a schedule,
doing any schoolwork or exercise.
I don't wanna push too hard
during this traumatic time
but my sibling has been resistant.
So, how do you convince people?
- That's a great question.
So, I kinda thought
about that a little bit.
I think really when you think about ways
where, what's engaging
to that person, what does
that person like?
This is a strategy in teaching
as well too is like getting
that person to choose
and identify the things that they like
and how can they use that to incorporate
into physical activity
and really identifying
what some of the immediate
benefits are with that.
What's the benefit of
being physically active.
So, if they're complaining
about, you know, "I'm
not sleeping well," well,
physical activity is a
great way to promote sleep,
figure out some of those things
of what they're going through.
I'm feeling lonely or.
I'm just kinda down in the
dumps about not being in school
and so those kinds of
things, physical activity
is a great way to kind of lift
moods and spirits and talking
about that and that really I mean part of,
if it's another teenager
or something, you know, young person
who isn't an adult, it's like,
well we can't get too out of
that routine, I mean,
we're gonna have to go
back to it eventually,
we're taking a you know
a big pause in our life,
but we wanna stick with,
sticking with the schedule,
it'll make us feel better physically,
it's gonna make us feel
better emotionally.
That's great advice and
what I'm finding, you know,
as my younger, my youngest
who's five years old.
Oftentimes, if you asked him
to do something directly, he
automatically resists, like,
take a bath, he's like, "no,"
let's go for a walk, he'll say, "no."
But if you do a little
bit of a deflection,
maybe stroke his ego a little bit, say,
"Hey, that was really amazing
how you got that stuff done."
"Hey, can we talk about it now,
I'm just gonna be outside,"
and as soon as they're outside then,
then all sorts of good stuff happens.
- Yes, yes that's true and
yesterday I remember even talking
about that praise too.
Point out the great things
that that person has, those strengths
and stuff like that, so
yes that's a great tip.
- Yeah, I hate to admit it
but I think it works with me as well, but.
(laughing)
- It does, we had a
running joke in my family
where, you know, if I wanted
to get my younger siblings
to do something all I had to
do was say, "I'll time you."
So. (laughing)
My, oldest is like that you measure it,
he wants to do it.
So let's see.
So, Facebook Lillian Carrera Cinco asks,
"What are your feelings
"about preschoolers incorporating yoga
"into their physical
activity for the day."
- I think it can be done well.
It's a good strategy of like stretching
and kinda using what
I mentioned earlier is
about that imaginative movement
so, if you're talking about
different things like cobra pose
and talking about let's, we
can be like Cobras and snakes
and getting into that position that way
and kinda just picking ones
that are fun for them to do, Child's Pose,
I think it's a nice
way to get them to move
and then again, asking them,
"well what are some different ways we
"can stretch our bodies together?"
and so allowing them to really explore.
So, with the little
ones, like preschool age,
it's about them being able
to explore the body movement,
how their body moves
in those kinds of ways.
So, Yoga is a great way to
kinda lead them into that
and then asking them what other animals
in nature can we move with.
- That's great.
And, you know, yoga itself.
My understanding is, it was
first developed thousands
of years ago in India as a way
of preparing the body for meditation.
So, there's an interesting aspect of it,
so, it's great to intersperse
it especially in this time
where people are just trying
to get into a better mental place as well
and not get too anxious and stressed out.
That yoga, not only is a physical
but can relax you and
then, get you focused
for other things.
- Absolutely.
- Let's see so.
There's a lot of questions, of here,
for Sophie Foster on YouTube
asks, "what kind of foods,
"would you eat to get more energized?"
After doing more PE or I guess
in general, more energized.
- That's a great, a great question.
So, carbohydrates are
usually foods that fuel you,
They are our body's number
one source of energy.
It kinda depends on what
you're trying to do.
If, you know, you're gonna do something
with an extended period of time,
so you know you're gonna go
for a more intense, longer.
You think about eating
carbs, complex carbs more
in the beginning of the day
but really you know bananas
and fruits, those are really good,
healthy carbohydrates for you
to eat that provide energy, eating.
You can eat a banana after a
workout or even before workout.
So, you know, really fruits
and vegetables are great ways
to to get that energy in.
And so you'll find too as
you become more active,
it increases your metabolism
and so you might become more hungry.
And so, just making sure
you're eating those healthy,
those healthy foods to fuel you.
- Yeah, and our brains use a large portion
of our calories too.
That's why, there's a lot of energy there
people don't realize it
and the other good thing
about fruits is vitamin C,
which obviously is valuable
for fending off viruses.
(laughing)
- Absolutely.
- So, let's see there's,
there's Kim Randall from Facebook asks,
"what should we do,
instead if we can't run,
"should we walk fast?"
Yeah, sometimes my knee
gives me troubles, you know,
there might be other reasons
why someone can't run,
what do you recommend?
- Yeah, I think I, to me walking
is such a great, it's very
effective, everybody can do it.
It's also if you plan
it throughout your day
it could be a great time
to bond with family,
and there's a lot of
different things you can do
to kinda make it a
little more interesting.
I'm speaking, again, towards
the younger children.
"Name 10 things that start
with the letter of your name
"that would see on our walk."
Maybe you do one day a noticing walk
where you're looking around
for things you've never noticed
before that maybe you've
never paid attention,
and it kinda goes into
that mindfulness piece
where you're practicing
being in the moment
and you're not thinking
about what's going to happen
or what has already happened.
And then you can add the
challenge of, let's not talk,
and then at the end of our walk,
we can kind of like, "well
did you notice this?"
and kind of compare.
One that I thought was good
was a social distancing walks.
so, can, if you're friends
with your neighbor, you know,
"hey let's take a walk,
you're on that side
"of the, on the other sidewalk,
"we're on this one and then
we can shadow each other."
So, taking turns kind
of like a follow the leader type of game.
And then, yeah, changing the
speed and tempo of your walk,
those are simple ways to do
it, you speed walk for a minute
and then you know leisurely
walk for 30 seconds
or, you know, going up and down
and that helps build
burn more calories too
if you can't do other more
intense forms of exercise.
- And I find walking, especially valuable
and this is more advice
for maybe the parents
but the students as well.
If you have a call.
Now, that we're working remotely to
and you just walk while you do it,
you don't even notice the time goes by
and you all of a sudden you
have like 5000 steps or 6000 steps.
Just from one call.
- Absolutely.
So, it looks like we're getting
more and more questions.
This is a very popular topic
but we're pretty much at time.
My apologies, both to you, Michelle
and everyone else for some of the
- No problem.
- technical difficulties.
I had on my end.
But thank you so much for joining.
I suspect that we'll have
more questions in future times
to ask Michelle so don't hesitate
to keep those questions coming,
but I'll just thank everyone for joining.
Once again, this is
just a way for all of us
to stay connected to support each other,
in what is a trying time.
I'll remind everyone again,
we are not for profit
so your donations are
very much appreciated
where we are running at a deficit.
And a reminder for tomorrow's show.
Our guest is Bill Gates,
and we're gonna talk a little bit
about, he's really well known
for many things as a philanthropist
as the founder of Microsoft,
but he's really been one of the people
who predicted this
pandemic many years ago,
he's been giving speeches
about it and he's been
at the center of the battle
so we're gonna talk a lot
about epidemiology tomorrow
and where all of this might lead.
So, thanks everyone for joining.